[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I'll start whoa going on
Hey hey there hi and welcome to a call
of duty stream we are getting excited I
would say yeah we got a new Call of Duty
coming out and we thought we'd like to
spend the time to go back and take a
look at the older classics which ones to
three and world at war I was unable to
get Call of Duty original running 2003
with that yeah the first one
yes 2030 yeah but two is a good start
it's a good start um my name is Rob
handler this is Michael Hardy hey and
also Michael hi oh hi I'm say that right
gh is silent
what so uh yeah the plan of the stream
is uh we're gonna play some old classics
you know World War two classic World War
two classics and then hopefully we'll
see a trailer for the upcoming Call of
Duty is it actually titled World War two
call duty over to the ww we Roman
numeral two so we'll be looking at that
trailer doing a little dissection of it
I got a laptop here with premiere ready
to go and yeah we're gonna smooth good
old-fashioned fun um so I thought for
call duty to that uh we played in a
movie engine I think we opened up with
d-day alright the Rangers on Pointe du
Hoc yeah what did that alright enough
for that let's do it cool place so uh
yeah you know anyone in chat I'm looking
at twitch in YouTube there uh you guys
got any questions or comments we'll be
reading those um wow this you've been a
while yeah what I really liked about
like the whole Call of Duty's World War
twos they felt like oh History Channel
documentary almost like the old-timey
voices over the old footage
maybe will the world at war which we'll
see you later you're like they moved a
little bit away from that
motion graphics but totally house
looking at some a world war you know it
is also interesting well get to world a
war I'm kind of interested to see it
because that's a weird game looking back
on it and that you know it's coming out
post of all those modern worker games or
post the first miner working right and
so they had a like I feel like modernize
it and you know you're you're like a
flame thrower and you're hearing like
Punk yes just like a heavy distorted
guitar it felt interesting I yeah I just
forgot about that game to be honest yeah
well that war had that uh that we've
with black ops cuz it's his name Rezanov
yeah resident Russian Russian soldier in
World War two and then it becomes the
pretty main character sticking bent
toward black ops
no well psycho rent or yeah that's a man
look at you can isolate a military
channel of watermark on it late yeah
what's for watching
military Channel documentary right now
that would be a good stream that would
be pretty dope I would be down for that
this take me back cuz I'd be watching
stuff like this when I was like 12
sure is it possible turn up uh Richard
this the audio here so we can hear a
little more of this oh we have rope we
have the controls with us
I have Freddie's journal entry set a set
them all up I actually like the Russian
campaign in this game a lot you start
off there people asking the chat when we
can show the trailer hopefully around 10
a.m. Pacific so an hour from now is when
we're expected to see something
battle point hockey's the u.s. Rangers
going up to secure those anti naval
batteries kind of man these
simultaneously these guards you know
that these landing crafts were made in
Louisiana
I had like Louisiana contractors out
there who generally made swamp boats to
like design these types of landing craft
that's pretty cool this would suck
being this guy like he's own hook
cannons Saving Private Ryan the chat
yeah pretty much give that someone's got
eyes if they do d-day and sledgehammers
game don't do Saving Private Ryan again
we know it's a great movie we've seen it
many times we played it a few times yeah
right
oh do that what yeah like what do you
guys want out of a World War 2 game well
like small story bits I mean we've seen
the big battles in movies and stuff but
if you like I think that if you're gonna
have do the big battles on a see
something lesser-known like I like the
Canadian invasion during d-day I don't
know maybe that's like two old gold Juno
and sword beaches yeah which weren't as
difficult as was a Utah Omaha and who's
the other one gold Juno and sword we're
Canadian Britta been British Canadian
British and then Omaha Utah Utah was the
one that they established to link up
with paratroopers who dropped in the
night before
that's like we've got band of brothers
was 81 a first Infantry I also I think I
also heard that like they did a bunch of
bombing raids prior to the invasion and
country coincidentally the American
beaches dislike weren't hit that well
like while they're like artillery and
bunkers were left intact making them for
quite oh I forgot the DOS rating Call of
Duty 2 it's just this you'd be clicking
the stick trial yeah
here that yeah oh and it's just instinct
yeah is your sensitivity pretty low yeah
but I was like it is Wow but it's 101st
airborne you minute yeah Michael was
saying infantry how about it I'm sure
you're one of your concert 14 seconds
yeah well you're saying is good point
like I think towards the later call
called a world war two games they you
know they did a lot of like jumping
around right the two did do a lot of
this starts in Russia then you go to the
British campaign in Africa and in France
right and then you come here um yeah
they always did the like the three-prong
campaign where you play as different
parts or different allies during the war
yeah I thought that was always that was
always sweet that they did that so
you're always getting different
perspectives different different
environments to like just playing and
you know jumping to the African campaign
and jumping back to France keep things a
little bit varied goggle three was all
France and yeah this tray arcs flight ha
damn
alright yeah people are chatter asking
well where is the trailer um let's see
what time is it now actually it is 907
Java way to go still about an hour out
from when we expect the trailer to drop
we'll be watching it here and talking
about it will be kind of breaking it
down I have a laptop here with the
ability to do frame by frame yeah and uh
yeah well what kind of a tap into the
nostalgia here with these World War 2
games call duty this is two right now
we'll be playing three and then we'll
dat war oh [ __ ] sorry okay I'll do that
Lopez yeah this is called duty to call
duty always did those presented the big
battles in such a grand way we actually
felt like chaos was happening yeah like
I I grew up playing a lot of Allied
assault but it was more of that one-man
army
type of campaign a call of duty one kind
of does that till towards the tail-end
but for the most part they always have
these grand battles which is always fun
to be in fun to experience mm-hmm and
kind of feel like you were there I think
Mike you and I are talking about
if the exciting just to hear and oh use
the m1 again cuz it's a pretty pretty
awesome gun no regards no real oh it's
just the the noise of it
pinging yeah I remember playing a Medal
of Honor frontline yeah like mashing the
reload button like yo how come this gun
isn't reloading sure a little did I know
that you cannot of course Thompson here
those leaked screenshots earlier this
week showed like soldiers holding Tommy
gun's holding Thompson's with the with
the drum to draw magazine it oh really
yeah I don't know if that's accurate hi
Vlad yeah
well it's
yeah people Machat uh some of them some
people might be a little confused this
is called Doody 2006 yeah I think was
2005 because I think this was a launch
360 game and then called duty 3 was in
2006 cuz I got that for Christmas
uh-huh the Box didn't have a disk in it
the Box did not is it was yeah it's
weird cuz it was a seal game and I was
like yeah I'll call of duty 3 I can't
wait to play this and he'll put it up
like this was sealed but there's no disc
in it so would you do
I just went to Best Buy and was like yo
um yeah the disc one of the first games
on the 360 I played hi this is what am i
doing I'm just out in the open let's get
in here it's all good
you're playing very realistically here
dude on veteran difficulty smoke
grenades and these games are essential
oh okay don't like you guys would you
guys play called vide games on veteran I
beat this on veteran no I think beating
this on veteran like the specific game
was one of my the hardest things I've
done up to not the hardest but on the
360 at least that was tough for the S
smoke grenades are huge I always I
always played a bomb coming into the
trench I was playing on normal
difficulty cuz some of the parts are
some of the parts in the campaigns are
really annoying when you don't know
where you're getting shot from and
you'll get shot like boys
yeah and die that's just great I guess
we're quite realistic but for the
purposes of playing through a video game
campaign it was a mildly frustrating to
put it mildly
yeah yeah I just like so chaotic that
it's hard to tell where things came from
sure
this [ __ ] is their David just man
just like grenade prompt and the noise
is enough like nostalgia right there
boga got mine still left I guess it's
just trotting along no anal thing yeah
I'd do it damn it I got to do it it's
worth it it's worth it get down
no I need that so what's the setting
here your your private I believe so yes
here we got got the Luger
where we going I think these guys are
facing the wrong direction odd-eyes
their sounds designs gonna know if
you're going the right direction I think
I am oh no I think you're right well you
guys know how close they are
this one's just hanging out okay yeah I
mean uh I'm hoping for a really
realistic experience yeah me job I was
thinking about it too I want to well
there folks
yeah to play it straight like you know
because when you when you craft
something around this source material
you know it's you can really rub people
the wrong way with if you do it wrong or
mm-hmm
like something like inglorious basterds
like was that was a very not like
playing it straight kind of tail with in
World War two your revenge fantasy right
yeah but I feel like for for a video
game you know I mean I have faith that
they will do something that's I guess
acceptable cuz they will call of duty
campaigns of boys more or less took
themselves seriously right it's the
multiplayer stuff that I'm like I don't
want to like have these spray-painted
skins on my yeah for red dot scope yeah
really cuz yeah I mean that's kind of
what world war had to kind of pull in
right was like you had that Mon where
her Martin warfare height and mean like
you can't just like roll back on it I
don't know what are you gonna do like
from a realistic sampling like it's just
one weapon right or anything you can't
just like tack on silencers whatever you
want um the good how gun Bert's wait
yeah world of warhead perks dead yeah um
call duty two and three did not I said
that was the I was in it soul o monarch
warfare one they brought that stuff out
you're like I as far as the campaign
goes I mean that I don't know I would
want something that isn't so cliche like
I don't care like like you know did you
mention the glorious bastards like I
hope that there isn't that ending scene
where you're you got an mp40 and
Hitler's face on the floor it's just the
worst you know I mean like I just I'm a
very like uh you know behind the Sun was
a dark TV in here yeah it is
I'm curious how sledgehammers World War
2 game will handle like attachments
remembering world of war they added
those don't aperture size just so you
could have a go red dot equivalent right
oh yeah ooh that's what we're saying I
hope but then you know how does that
work for multiplayer then like is that
would that be fun if it so much
oh yeah we're like we're so used to
modding weapons now right like I just
like such a standard 4:19 just call duty
like like maybe we don't or we don't
know that we don't want that anymore
right right give us the bare-bones and
then leave it up to us to kind of you
know win these matches that we're gonna
play or maybe they'll have new game
modes
I haven't played Call Duty multiplayer
and so long that I don't know like
Search and Destroy is still a thing now
pardon my lack of knowledge there but
y'all playing Search and Destroy in Call
of Duty one and Call of Duty twos like
peek multiplayer times when I was a
teenager so I it's been so long since I
played that style of multiplayer in a
world war two no laughs it's been so
long since we played any World War two
game but
with with today's technology I'm also
I'm looking at this and they're
portraying a grand battle there's so
many moving parts and all these
explosions going on everywhere with
today's tech you can almost MIT take
that to the next level have higher light
count of NPCs around and they could feel
more full mmm like yeah like I even just
a I write like guys we saw earlier like
there was there were literally like five
feet away just like lines of enemies
they're like shooting at you like if you
put what if you could wall run just one
just one and accuracy in wall running
you could double jello maja beach man no
don't do that for those of you joining
us this is called 82 we're actually
probably gonna switch over and about
four men shirts I think you something a
little more Oh we'll go discover that
the guns have been moved since the last
Intel thing and then we come back come
back I mean hell you can even jump
around and do it a mission if you want
yeah that's it um we the plan is for the
stream is we're gonna hang around till
at 10 a.m. Pacific when we expect the
trailer and as well as more info on the
upcoming Call of Duty World War 2 game
made by sledgehammer uh we're gonna take
a look at that trailer live here and
comb through it
Vasiliy cost la that's a table leslie
wolf leaked these mission russian
missions are so cold just fuel I just
feel cold playing them totally geez man
like we're gonna had old photos there's
hardly any I can barely dig up photos of
from like the Russian Eastern European
front just as likes to study history and
every time it's just like blanketed snow
mmm what is that man these guns I don't
remember svt-40 this is PPSh this PC
seems like this is like the best
submachine gun of the war damn damn yeah
it was like what
got that like it's got that X for a
muzzle flash weird mmm Opie and
multiplayer if you ask me
yeah absolutely well then I definitely
remember using in a wallet war yeah I
played the hell out that multiplayer
asked for sure good world of war
yeah [ __ ] I kind of got burnt out on
multiplayer by that point which is
pretty early on and if you think about
it and the call of duty
wipes pan yeah but you [ __ ] oh that
was rare feedbag
oh another one back
we are playing on xbox one but
backwards-compatible is this to 1080p
[Music]
you said 2005 versus yeah as 2005 and
before this was United all manum I don't
know if y'all play united offensive
which is the yeah call duty one
expansion pack that was really sweet I
really like that a lot
wow that was the first time call duty
had vehicles actually in multiplayer
right but it was pretty janky actually
it's like oh here's a bigger Call of
Duty map and we'll have a jeep that uh
kind of doesn't work entirely perfect my
Auto a was just picking someone up in
the smoke he's thought oh I hate that
noise annoys me doesn't say oh wow man
that's cold
I didn't throw it just watch boy oh no
thought that was your thought that was
just not with these yeah this clearly
isn't the best place but I got more of
these
you have plenty of Rene's all that our
smokes time to the checkpoint but you
got 4x - potato mashes
oh boy hole is not cover their thought
there was
[Music]
this thing is hard to just go into two
nuts right yeah it doesn't really have
much range for dudes me I was always all
about the semi-auto long-range rifles
and I'm one especially oh I played most
of this stuff on PC so yeah that made it
a lot easier to use those type of guns
kalla t2 is also the one of the first
games where my friends actually got
together and did organized matches
outside of counter-strike oh yeah yeah
arm it involved tonight ts combat it
balls to waste on my halo halo 2 was
Mahadev for me of like LAN parties and
[ __ ] oh yes I'm links yeah like like
living room upstairs basement downstairs
and then if we got if we want to get
daring and use that try splitter it
would be a third TV so we have three
teen - - oh my god we got into it oh
that's pretty so not getting up oh no
literally like I can't think of any
other games like is that it where uh it
was a wagon and like TVs and we would my
buddy lived close enough where we could
just drag all this stuff over to her
garage when that's like requiem for a
journey and when he steals is my CD it
felt like it and if you saw this TV he
would have even like further agree with
that like it was pathetic
this TV this is before we all had like
flat screens dude
oh my god yeah these things had stickers
all over it cracked
yeah about and worst player had to play
on it why am i hearing Joe [ __ ]
oh yeah nobody's back whiskey I don't
think so no no like what are you trying
let's give it in give it a shot I've
tried already all right you guys wasn't
standing over it ya know the no sprint
is the one that it's bomb yeah cuz I
can't remember three had it we'll find
out soon Lyoness much over try try see
if you can uh toss back if you need then
I think yeah definitely switch over
throw one now I gotta get them to throw
one for now talk to you he can throw it
back throw that's knowledge machine gun
he's [ __ ] thing don't let me kill him
get him a Nader
Carol Ralph
yeah yeah yeah almost positive you can
this game some of the multiplayer
servers had like those mods where you
can really they literally added sprint
server side that was pretty sweet girl
we're gonna eat at me I've good clothes
done we need dedicated server browsers
for all those wacky modded things mm-hmm
that I used to see him 1 & 2 all right
blow it oh man remember the sticky bomb
scene and Private Ryan had a one guy
yeah oh she's the unfortunate
I shouldn't have been watching that
stuff man I was like 9 years old and all
right Lilly is so messed up oh all right
victor/victoria tradition Wow whatever
did we switch off the wool is Oliver you
uh-oh
so I called a three all right how do you
need
it's a disc I think right this is
jean-luc come in for the disc Oh that
our DN no you're right we're gonna have
to have it's it's already in the daddies
are already in pastiche
I don't you haven't used an Xbox and so
long oh my hand is here or is it your
hands sweaty oh it was nervous he's
there it's not he's excited he's excited
if you're just joining us we are hanging
out we got what 35-ish
minutes until what we expect uh alright
uh 55 37 35 who knows we don't but we're
waiting for the trailer for the coming
Call of Duty one more two game mean by
sledgehammer we're gonna hang out and
play older classics like now call duty
three Treyarch first called what would
be a good mission so there's some good
ones where you're clearing houses as the
French Resistance I think it might be
hostage well on go uh go left
crossroad me no keep going left before
chapter 10 for not the four is not like
filets road might be it but keep going
left
I don't do everyone all right Alan let's
do a night job well sir off my DS and if
you guys can chat want to see any
specific levels in um called you three
well we'll go ahead and load them up
yeah oh wow kind of boy that uh is this
price no price is somewhere in here I
didn't know I was gonna get into some
some Call of Duty Lord here no this
happens old-timey stuff like the way
they kind of present the stories and
some of these earlier games remind me of
the World War two movies like John Wayne
and because my dad is always walking so
much to uh our cam so I can put turn
those off because people keep sending us
well well we'll see um if you pressed
both the story always so if you want to
cut the camera we can switch it but
we'll wait for now if you press blue
starts like the same time system on the
old-school Xbox Guide you should be able
to go to it listen to that music man I
know just Riegel's [ __ ]
say ask me badass
your sis modern warfare in the very
beginning it's not a very beginning but
the UH uh not turn these off what's up
oh we're gonna quickly turn off the
notifications closer sure thing you know
people want to friend up ah settings
he's I'm kind of hollow yeah so Rob what
are we doing here on this stream for
people just joining that's a really good
question we are playing Call of Duty 3
and after this world at war the plan is
we're gonna hang out and play these
games until we see hopefully and
expectedly the upcoming trailer for the
upcoming game I got call of duty world
at war we are doing a little setting
change here gonna turn off those
notifications I don't know where it is
do you what's interesting is actually
going back I think it's an Xbox 360 yeah
the thing is you go to the actual uh not
strange HUD opposed to BAM sweet we
rockin and rollin and we're back via
black just a night drop at a nice a
night drop last night if you do I mean
an eye drop drop top what come in a few
things actually now that I think of it
who Wow I really need my glasses you
wear glasses you're not wearing a murder
I lost them I lose glasses perpetually
and my prescription ran out oh no no
don't do it please don't
oh well you sure got shot in the head
man that helmet sure didn't do anything
oh [ __ ] this is the mission where you
meet yeah Lisbon where you meet the
resistance
don't act like you knew you were lying
when you said he was gonna roast me
ah no sprinting unless I sprint is
disabled at this point
oh you have a grease gun yeah Sten you
know that's no greasy I was amazing yeah
all right this is the stand your
absolute then got that clip coming out
the side right without Keith so corporal
we don't see sweat meet your need
growing into oil dam like sea biology
and just makes me want to play
Wolfenstein the new order
oh no not Return to Castle Wolfenstein
return account turned a casual way
better Mike or Michael you agree with me
yeah returning Castle Wolfenstein is
another iconic multiplayer game you guys
are so much oh gee thanks man new people
in chat agree to not new orders good
though new order is good but orders real
good turn to Castle Wolfenstein man yeah
a game changed my life it did because if
that was multiplayer campaign can't both
both I am otherwise I'm way way more
multiplayer was awesome and oh all those
physics yeah yeah there's a grad dojo in
this game that was weird
like Dark Souls everyone's I've heard it
here called three three is a Dark Souls
desk oh so boys order how making a chat
oh my god oh my god
well players went up oh I'm really bad
at this
yeah what's what's I got all to me so I
gotta fix those simple console skills
yeah shouldn't give me love keyboard
this is this actually didn't come out of
the house would not have it sure I'll
take an mp40 oh man I got roasted man
live on stream you do get roasted okay
oh man but much more quotes later little
opinion oh nice sales bet that melee
stuff were you knocking with the butt of
your gun cousin why invade dieback come
on man Oh me beckon uh yeah that one
comes like Nate don't okay also don't
walk right up wow those yeah there's
people in a while alright yeah I'll meet
y'all the spot for me cuz I can't spot
for myself
yeah you guys just joining us this is a
Call of Duty three
and about half an hour will hopefully be
seeing the trailer dropped for the
upcoming properly dressed some of those
dudes on your left are call duty 12
hours yeah look like you're like a nice
suit
look at that dude he looks like a penis
so [ __ ] bad-ass he's probably looking
good during war it's probably got sure
it stays on dude those are clutch yeah
this is that TV that darkens Oh like it
automatically adjusts the plans
oh is that what we're seeing about
settings the same only used for a Red
Dead oh my god let's go in this house we
must protect this hot Matthew licenses
uh oh snap I'm getting shuffled Oh
laughs these graphics don't look very
good what oh damn sledgehammer what's
your deal what do you think what year
was this 2006 this was so this wasn't a
year on the year yearly X here those of
the other took out the second do they
come away what every year man man I
don't get any made a missus you're the
three studio rotation until well I don't
know who made this look like movie this
is treyarch game cuz sledgehammer didn't
get into the rotation until modern
warfare 3 which they helped work our
Infinity Ward and sledgehammer did
modern warfare 3 all car 98
that rare didn't enter like a new era
until blackops which was after modern
warfare 2 from the mistaken boom boom
2010
this bolt-action life is tough the first
blackouts were my favorite call duties
do you know the best-selling Call of
Duty game is it's a great question I
don't know black ops 2 by a wool number
we when we shot that stuff the studio
it's like by a long shot
I don't know what that was yeah this
week I figured the fatigue would have
set in by then like up to one thousand
to twelve thousand twelve yeah how's it
too tricky doesn't what's that just
because black ops was pretty much your
scene cuz I like black but yeah I think
that was the peak before it trailed off
a called II and dressed as the next one
after Black Ops II would have been want
to wear fur no tripping [ __ ] no that
would go sit oh yeah
was it oh snap ghost and then go some
black ghost in the advanced warfare
black ops 3 I actually just played
advanced warfare a campaign a couple
months ago cuz I haven't played call
duty in like seven years or yeah
seriously I'm like some man I'm stuck
ups oh it's not a ps2 game this is a 360
actually didn't like that much um
advanced warfare no Kevin Spacey was
dope but like that's about it at least
watching house of cards or that or
American Beauty what you're seeing is
advanced warfare alright moving on from
that uh let's think about to a new
mission yeah what do we need so what do
we want from World War two game I'll
think about it
if you really wanted to like portray
realism like the only customization
would would be like what like just perks
you know quickly I mean we're not gonna
lean on that I highly highly doubt
they'll ask you that you know perk
loadout attachment systems I think you
think oh you like black ops 2 the first
one they had the pick 10 system and then
that has stuck they still had that in a
version of that infinite warfare which I
liked infinite warfare actually as far
as Call of Duty games go a lot so
shampoo was the last I'm not gonna do
that
yeah do probably consider warfare to and
then you know theoretically infinite
Infinity Ward will do like infant
warfare two in two years if they keep
going with that which I think they will
remains to be seen what I'm excited see
what Treyarch does it now that black ops
is theoretically closed out
well they had a Polish campaign I
totally forgot about that the resist
your resistance right I think so yeah
cuz Poland didn't have a formal army
that's a tank sequences here - oh you
didn't you're not driving though right
you're just miss call of duty - but
African campaign there's one where
you're driving the tank mm I think
you're driving you want to know my
favorite World War two games are though
I think it's Brothers in Arms earned in
blood at least is one of my favorite to
you you could get through that campaign
without firing because your AI was so
good when you're commanding them it's
got be smart get him in the right
position flanking and [ __ ] and then the
actual iron sights were kind of a little
off so it felt a little more real
yeah like you could get away with that's
weird yet one-man-army crossfade - why
were they showing that what was the
point of showing that soldier American
show from but from the Germans point of
view I don't know
I don't was that impact man oh my gosh
it's for chaos man
and I forgot a lot about this game good
lord
I remember the multiplayer being all
that great four distinct to me at least
they did have that in match ranking up
so I buy like 10 kills you get like an
extra Chevron next to your names yeah I
don't know if it I don't think I didn't
get anything
it was just like y'all look at me I'm
with the I got like 40 kills and I'm
like did it not give you anything I
don't think you got like any person
tanks and multiplayer in this I got
Thompson and I got a m1 grand alright
let's go
you're set yeah dude that's like though
that's the classic two gun loadout in
the world war two game oh the xtg 44 oh
dude that was every World War 2 game
like if I could pick that up all right
I'll be the soldier like it's over so a
precursor of a old low deal or bouncing
Betties oh my gosh he's got those are
colossal and you uh is this one of the
games that started introducing like
manual reload for the garand even though
it wasn't story but ya know so he got
shoot l8 to reload oh really so that
they did end up like switching that when
yeah and world of war you could which
was weird I think they just it was a
gamey thing but you know historically
you had to eject expend the entire
bandolier before it or you had the
entrance praying out hmm
yeah so like I was telling Rob the other
day actually fired an m1 before and that
ping you hear when it shoots out is like
just as loud as it sounds these games
it's like made my ears ring deafening
but it was it was pretty cool
I remember hearing like an anecdote
World War 2 anecdote that it was almost
dangerous for that to go off cuz then
the enemy would know wouldn't know that
you were literally an
I'd say that that's interesting yeah I
mean if you wanted because yeah I think
was metal have on her front line on ps2
that if I had one bullet left in the
bandolier I would just fired into the
sky to reload or no she's lasted well
don't keep going in there now I got to
go we got to push forward
oh ho Jesus will get out of her day
Morrow I feel so bad you should get this
guy's glasses for real there's just a
character Michael plays and games don't
have his glasses on who just say I all
the time my glasses I can't see anything
about my glasses
Oh God
that's right minutes meaning we should
well I don't wake up to I don't really
care who lasts as I do i this yeah I'd
say let's play World War they like I
want to try and do the Raygun Easter Egg
oh my god it's [ __ ] it's cool dad
here it's a civilian you're not joking I
promise you people to chat Rob doesn't
believe me that you can get the Reagan
on Iwo Jima by jumping into this pun and
then I want to see you I want to see
that oh great I see some secret weapons
of world war ii stuff right now
that's good deal see that is one of the
best battlefield DLC used in existence
II always see your weapons of World War
two oh well from 1942 yeah that'll be
favorite it's one they just said f it is
through in like helicopters well let's
go out guys gentlemen like jet pad
German dude just go with like segs in
the errands it's hilarious it was like
it was you know you know Hitler his
crazy like he had some ideas ideas
exactly about that's I like Wolfenstein
is actually Slyke loosely I'm not
kidding I'm not just trying to pimp stop
like I'm yeah anything I didn't say that
it is loosely actually based on like
deranged weapon ideas that Nazi tell ya
like the v2 rocket was real like gravity
dreams about it and like that became a
thing Verner Wernher von Braun like
helped develop it and then like you see
October sky it was unknown how like
locked up he actually was in terms like
knowing what was going on in death camps
and stuff we got some QTE come on
oh-oh-oh-oh-oh-oh our Saving Private
Ryan scene I remember really get
legitimately as the primary guy looks
like him too and that scene is I'm
throwing possible
I want seems like horror movies and I
that is what I thought
I watch a lot of where are their
brothers where you're yeah wait he's on
a stairwell oh boy Wittering they don't
got my back cuz I shot one I don't like
any of this I know yeah this is the
first time I think QTE was introduced in
oh god call the duty so after I murk
this do I think we can move on Markham
for damage get on Alice they're just
going for that team
oh that's brutal man I'm glad I didn't
have to see it yeah anyone actually ever
pulled that off ready world at war I
think we actually don't need to switch
discs now yeah we're gonna switch it
over but keep playing yeah
oh snap I'll keep playing Oh Rob you fi
take the range for where do you want I
can absolutely take the rat uh we are
loading up world at war probably switch
over over to uh and we got ya about I'll
do enough time to show that Raygun
Easter Egg less than 20 minutes we're
hoping yeah so people destroy me we got
YouTube twitch chats up yeah we're
looking at chat it's moving pretty quick
but uh were lookin hey how you guys feel
playing through these old games like
will I realize how much I didn't
actually like Call of Duty 3 and how
much I did like call duty - OH
hmm I called you three over like I
remember it becoming more of a weird
it like you just saw that instead of but
yeah what punching the guy repeatedly he
pulled the pin on a grenade and that
scene was drawn out it was a little thin
it was the early days of qt
I suppose cuz I'm like there's another
mission in three where are you like you
have to plant this bomb and they make
you like press X and then twist it this
way press a pull this and then you
present on the bright shiny Sun recruit
just no regular I'm gonna skip all this
touch my shell people before see this
all talk about like with the motion
graphics like this was pretty dope
actually I really liked like this New
Age sort of historical documentary style
interspersed with oh god it's cool
footage and the Pacific Theatre was nuts
mm-hm man I mean oh my god I don't thing
there seems really
ie Hallie I'm sorry not Steve Akira so
then what's his name Jack Bauer
what's his Kiefer Sutherland's supporter
right there
robots voice mm-hmm I think robot is
kind of an anagram of a Jack Bauer
almost people pointed out he just
rearranged stuff that's not a joke I
realize that's something I would say
halleloo is [ __ ] that's I think that's
the first combat that they were in the
Pacific do you watch that I'm assuming
no I never finished that series um heard
was okay I don't know if it was in
Jordan I actually think it's a little
underrated because if they focus more on
like the PTSD aspects cuz you're Anna
Rose gets into that later right and like
those last two episode but the Pacific
is like all throughout like kind of more
psychological but uh yeah it's not as
flashy as Band of Brothers I don't think
those last few episodes of band brothers
were actually like some of my favorite
yeah um yeah and everything yeah when
everything calms down and the other
going through points and stuff and
they're playing baseball when they hear
that yeah it was like the shellings
oh yes it is Shannon [ __ ] yeah it's
chilling that the war was over and
they're still technically fighting like
you know themselves and everything and
it's like they're just want to go home
right yeah they don't know if they're
gonna be sent to the Pacific like no I
can drive let die in like Boveri after
the war's over is the worst oh I think
survive yeah someone panels
you should hmm
wonderful she's like it's interesting to
think like do we want these these
moments right I don't want another
amphibious landing we've seen enough
like yeah I feel like every developer
that does it is like we want to bring us
into the modern era but then you don't
really do all that much different it's
kind of like Hoth like I don't want to
see huh yeah well as cool as it was at a
time yeah um yeah we don't want ha we
don't see you got manual reload now I
mean I guess I would have done that if
you pulled it back but does I wonder if
it like expends all of your like you'll
get rid of what's left and then it will
also take eight bullets out oh no it
doesn't that's a can't do that don't do
that unless you like stopped to reload
the bandolier itself in the middle of
the well I got [ __ ] oh I should do
this quick actually you should have
played on Rick what happened
Oh ain't no shame in playing on easy
dude mom well that's right you're
showing us a trick I'm like yes so yeah
I could get up there call that at first
I can move up so what's the story behind
the Raygun and its historical accuracy
sorry acted hoarse Oracle accuracy I
have no idea but alright every goes the
artillery let's go damn I can [ __ ] just
bombard them Christ
good [ __ ] and I like it was a Iwo
Jima they naval bombarded it for about
forget how long they spent nor the
collective like tonnage of what the hit
was but then of course there's still
some Japanese soldiers left in the caves
and stuff Eddie in the chat mentioned
the mg42 Wow
oh geez to one hell of a weapon alright
so I don't think it's yet [ __ ] is it
yeah this is a one of war plays of us um
joining us there's puddles alright bear
with me I'm naka if it gets drawn out I
won't do it but I think I know how to do
Oh sprint sweet thank you we believe in
you man spread all right all right so
bear with me I swear this looks weird
trying to get the Raygun for those of
you maybe more people get citrus through
this I am fairly certain you have to
jump into these puddles wait like a few
seconds in each one and then get out and
get to the next one I'm not even kidding
that's not a puddle hole yeah whatever
really maybe it's farther up the beach
after you follow the tanks cuz tour
knows on here though oh man
this is there's a puddle there oh that
one I think you end up and maybe that
one all right one more time let me try
it one more time I think it might be a
fair follow tanks up but this is more
interesting if you like then watching
okay mhm
I feel the Stork accuracy yes if you
don't jump into the puddles so maybe
just the puddles uh-huh
yeah Wow how I thought you the Crouch
too but I'll do that just in case I mean
the only way this gets out is if one of
the developers setting out leaks in
right what like mine the files or
whatever oh that's good point
mmm no does it just like pop up in your
uh it's one more interrupted yes yes you
didn't believe me where is it what the
yeah oh you thought I was oh man that
[ __ ] nuts what the hell yeah let's go
but watch you didn't see the documentary
on this haha you I told you watch the
Pacific they talk all hangs we're not
joking around and then this guy he stood
in these final render for walking he
took the ray gun and shove it up his ass
much everything cuz it things are you
nuts
alright Eddie I don't reckon on sorry
there the first time I did that I was
like my friend must be [ __ ]
I heard that that was back like honestly
the internet was around when this game
came out but that was still like when
things could happen word of mouth before
like a game like Zelda came out when
people would mind
they wouldn't have liked Apple you just
happened now people would have mind of
files like long before it said oh this
is the next Titan Titan fall or
something you had to like figure this
[ __ ] out
this is really weird to watch this I'm
sorry you just said about how much time
we have left
while I'm Reagan oh oh super good
question ten minutes Rock all right
we're pushing about ten minutes we're
expecting the trailer for the next Call
of Duty World War two they said they're
not doing the Pacific I don't know if
they're pretty sure it spoke I don't
know if they said anything but well I
mean based on the coverage yes yeah it's
classic like well I guess that could
have been mmm it's good point was he did
he have did he have the fish nets on his
helmet yeah
why Marines did that though in a Pacific
yeah that's why I was at wondering wait
I think stole how dumb is this this is
pretty dope I think actually why cuz you
could get in call duty zombies from the
random weapon box this being the first
game that introduced Tommy's on
knockdown totin which you thought that's
kind of a spoiler in a later game in the
series you go back to that like during
the campaign it's super really we asked
happens uh probably didn't plan almost I
don't know if I people care about
whisper in my ear I got a microphone oh
look I whispered both our microphones
I'll tell you later but I mean you can
kind of assume which developer it is but
you actually go back to that thing in a
campaign and I know it sounds weird but
it gets weird
oh [ __ ] and I'm gonna have this sorry I
forgot I had that mortar strike I was
too focused on this alien blaster that
seems morphing and he had that Reagan
top man
goddamn [ __ ] that's dead
what about right gun that we're waiting
for the trailer sayin Michael what what
about the ray gun kills people's it like
what about superhot like you just like
burn sure sure asthma I don't know looks
like the sonic blaster my Battlefront
- was it uh they had who wasn't one of
those they did sonic imploded televised
heaven I think yeah you want the grenade
something like that then float or
whatever oh no you know what I'm
thinking of in a oh my go lordy Lord
Mike no put it on my leg good someone
get that no we're good
move on uh I can't talk no your mic is
still on dude oh wait what the hell
happened no isn't your mic on
who knows on my leg he's good right no
he's not good come on fell
come at me with a bayonet boy I got a
Raygun you've two mics on Miss me with
this sorry just keep going oh good we're
totally good we're good we always been
good here's put it in your pocket thing
Oh No Oh
some cutie a cutie you were just in your
mic in the game your hold on one second
and you got bayonetted that would relat
hurt to get yep nearly what hurts more
ray gun or bayonet that's right I still
don't understand how this ray gun work
dude
like show me that documentary ha ha whoa
oh lordy Lord
well the rage oh oh snap Reagan was uh
was pretty pretty important to have in
zombies that's for sure oh yeah and the
wound of that one it was Luda Vasa I
think was the Electric Gun I was a
Blasius come at me boy got a ray gun god
I'm never playing that so much like my
buddy and whoever got the ray gun first
you just like damn like oh I got the ray
gun oh that's what i'm keep killing my
homies man um I feel so bad oh we got a
flank right now hey if you're uh joining
us we're gonna have got about seven
minutes um not very good at this all
right open
what uh what let's go new mission plan
is uh Brezhnev you can the trailer on
the slap here we'll watch it first maybe
watch twice and then we'll uh you know
break it down comb through it I'm really
I'm actually when I thought about it
yesterday
awesome I'm actually excited for this
yeah I'm
I haven't been excited for a call of
duty since like a long last time yeah
I'm I'm excited as why I want to see a
man I mean you know with the state and
the tack around Kern you know a systems
like what a world war qi game would look
like you know like mm-hmm
all right I can look really weird I
don't think it'll look all that
different it's just I don't know man I
one part of me even wants like a more
nuanced story like a tale from World War
two we haven't heard before but all at
the same time I want like even bigger
battles to feel even more full like I
mentioned earlier mm-hmm
so if they do those things I mean I
would be super interested in plankton
okay I'm gonna play through it anyway
just because it's been so long since we
had a World War two game and you know
still an interesting era to learn more
about or kind of experience through
dandy sinker [ __ ] games movies and
books
I think these planes are called the
carrot Catalina's I just had black hat
that's it's their squad Oh gotcha let's
I played this campaign pretty recently
because uh when I first got world at war
I just jumped into the multiplayer mm I
played this in like 2014 lol very dope
yes that's I mean I didn't it wasn't
unfortunately it wasn't as memorable for
me maybe just cuz we played so many of
these by that time we played so many of
these games at yeah we you know it's
just like like I said modern warfare was
out as well
yeah you guys ever see uh [ __ ] Memphis
Belle was at the movie above a b-17
squad Quadron um bomb squadron that was
Bell was the at least it was just like
you know the life of um like a bomb or
squad and like just there up there with
like you know like um very little armor
but like just when they hear flak just
like flak ripping through their plane
and your blood is like thinned up there
and just getting hit like I don't know
it's just like a really intense thing
you know in our turret area
call duty had a lot of the campaigns add
a lot of ease on Rails moments which are
probably my least favorite and like I
think they're trying to emulate them
ac-130 missions in the first game books
from moment warfare at this point okay
yeah no I mean they had them yeah like
in call duty one there is a lot of like
car chase sequences where I'm yeah I got
that what's that British gun with that
little the top-loading clip anyways
friend she's a brand yeah I was like
that off the side of a truck or leg
driving down the French countryside like
that kind of stuff is like I guess yeah
[ __ ] like it's weird too cuz yeah
turret sequences and on Rails things
were like the thing and shooters for a
while they're actually really hard to
make like for from the developer
standpoint the scripting involved it's
actually harder to make those oh so just
they felt like it was like I talked to
people a lot about it like a retired
like the taught titanfall to developers
and they were saying you know like they
were the thing for a while but it
actually like it was more thing passed
down saying you have to have this but
they took a while to get right mm-hmm
ten fall to developers Vince ampulla was
on the team that made call duty 1 and my
yeah yeah in the beginning yeah original
og Infinity Ward him and was it was Glen
Schofield there yet or no I don't know
cuz he was a he was sledgehammer or he
is sledgehammer still I think uh we want
to switch over yet her got solution for
to what now we're playing until you know
we're kind of winging it um we're
expecting something at 10 a.m.
um what do we go and switch over to call
their site or we're gonna stream well
know what the plan is Eric turning the
back will give me the video file and a
thumb drive and I'll put it on this
laptop here and we'll watch it through
once or twice and then we'll kind of
talk about it Mike I know you know a lot
about World War 2 maybe even like what I
any battles I'm expecting them to show
something right like setting and yeah
theater I guess sure I'm curious to see
so the guy the cover of that leaked
image definitely looked American here I
see with whether it be Marines Army
Pacific right I have a hard time
believing in the first world war two at
a long time they wouldn't go back to
European theater at all that is you know
like that is the one that is kind of
representative of the war and a lot of
our minds but not to diminish the
Japanese on this is will door wall that
war was what we're playing right now
talking to you you're saying no I'm just
saying I'm very surprised we didn't at
least see some sort of European theater
actually what I would like them to jump
back and forth somehow has any other
haven't died sitting in European this
game oh yeah you're the Russian going
into Germany the ending is Berlin I
believe yeah you're putting up the flag
in the end yeah and then at the end
they're like this many soldiers died
it's like this weird attempt to like
human eyes even eyes guess yeah
all right we're hitting that yeah it's
10 okay so just keep playing we'll wait
and see if we will see uh there's a
trailer if not well there's gonna be
celery there should be a joke I mean if
not we know look we have a lobby at
11:00 so will the live show here we'll
have to transfer over into that and
we'll talk about it there yeah but I'm
really hoping for it
I'm hearing them I'm hearing people in
the back
bang bang bang bang the stuff goes on
for a long time
it's ask you've seen people say it's out
let's we'll hang tight yeah we'll get on
that in a minute give us give us a
minute
Oh zeros that's really crazy - is like
how many manufacturers were like common
via car companies now like with mr.
beachy made the zero
you know Boeing obviously and
wonderful get some air combat kind of
like what battlefield one did whether
like mixing up the gameplay with me but
I mean Call of Duty has done it before I
don't know they said that return to the
roots I don't know if we give too much
vehicle I don't know if I want I never
been a chichi I mean like like I was the
game um was one of the battlefields did
it I think it was a battlefield three or
four we're like it's this epic walk from
a aircraft carrier to the flight deck
you get in and all you do is just fire
what you don't you don't know you don't
even fly the plane you just fire the
rocket oh I think those it was implied
for I think this forest was three or
four kind of blur together for me God
that was one of the most frustrating
things was like it was this huge Walker
he's like getting pumped up it's like oh
god man those battle plane not really on
topic but three and four battlefield 3
and four of those campaigns were I was
not a fan of those
yeah
hang tight for those of you Woodward
with us which I can probably check on my
phone to see if the trailer is at least
on site people in the back are gonna
give us the trailer so we can check it
out yeah can they like I can they at
least let us know what's going on
because I don't really know it all hey
John Luke yeah uh hopefully hey well the
meantime we're just blessed in ships
trailer plate but it's kind of like I
have a lag recording just do that but
like look I don't want to wait no longer
yeah okay laggy recording huh all right
so just because it's a twitch recording
I don't have like I have to get a proper
thing okay Carter might not discard it
on the side it's not trying to get that
visual work but there's nothing holidays
okay so people watching you gonna yeah
we have a recording of it from the
stream because they're doing a stream
right now it's this version is
apparently a little laggy but if you
give me a second I'm gonna load it up um
keep playing okay in the meantime let's
talk about twitch right they just we
just captured on twitch mm-hmm okay
that's right the capture on twitch so
it's gonna be a little laggy but we can
still check it out oh man I'm excited to
see what they're they're showing
yeah
but again it is a trailer leg I don't
like to read too much into trailers
because obviously is going to be very
different from the final product where
action in the play yeah but all right
but yeah for those joining we are about
to play the trailer I don't feel like
talking about this mission anymore
drawing sake
real quick yeah we like here no I want
dude this is okay the the format of this
doesn't seem to be working on this
computer
you love it how long you been into this
mission yo I don't know this is a long
mission
yeah Eric this formats not going to work
here oh I'll go change
I'll go put on them yeah we can also
just play the last year with a guy
talking let's do that I'd rather than
much rather dad right now the guys I'm
looking for right now okay oh wait we
have it hang tight
we almost there we almost there like
this would be something I wouldn't yeah
a long line out real real shooting
sequence right I'm sure this is a
something of the past that they wouldn't
really want to bring back unless it has
some sort of impactful like piece of the
story to it as long as it's not like 30
20 minutes long
it's at the end of it thank so you film
a few doctors there I think you failed
out on purpose but it's all good
dope hang tight
whoo can we see this man
backquote I'll just join me we just
reduce your act a just brought over the
trailer for us to play we got it
people are saying a lot of them saw it
I'm pretty excited to see this maybe to
one nice is two minutes actual games
over yeah we're good
hold one second guys cool all right so
we have the call duty world at war
trailer here switch over this day of set
upon a mighty endeavor
you
this day of set upon a mighty endeavor
souls will be taken with the violence's
of law in this hour of great sacrifice
we stop prevail
we are all that separates the world from
darkness the enemy is useless
cannot we must not fail duty first
[Music]
[Music]
how many casualties we executed the
mission get me the [ __ ] Eddie how many
we had orders
lieutenant tell him what we're all about
no mission too difficult no sacrifice
too great
welcome to the bloody first you're a
long way from Texas farm boy
interesting interesting
so yeah Rob you're the first one to
point out I was a big red one blade
first so as of now from what we just saw
that was all European - your army when I
scrub through it or you want to watch
again or what yeah let's just kind of
pause when we want um I know
well things um kind of supporting just
he had start off on man from the d-day
is this d-day actually I mean it must be
like those those landing crafts were
only really used for Normandy no um
that dudes an actual actor the one they
keep showing he was in the black
Donnelly's awhile ago which is the
short-lived show that I watched rewind
rewind rewind come on
this guy yeah so he was from yeah he's
in the black Donnelly's forget his name
I'd have to look that up but uh yeah
d-day hmm
landing craft obviously it's just great
Private Ryan
like the same side of the boat yeah well
oh wait wait go back
who's this dude that's a he's also an
actor - there's no capping everyone knew
then that they different marble that's
what I was vital say he looks the Romans
looks reminisce another guy similar it's
funny that you mentioned that you know I
don't want to see another d-day
amphibious I think they open up with it
that shot right there's a Private Ryan
that shots from super right really it
really is a silhouette of the gunner
like yeah there's your m1 yeah grease
gun
we always separate hmm he said oh is
that an English soldier yeah those are
p-47s those are friggin awesome plans
are they real British no American they
were like they were in the plane that
was before the p-51 Mustang which we
must know yeah dudes British huh this
looks at all very neighbor ara sorry
Sherman's mm-hmm Abrams are the moderate
action that's it for that that famous
horn is is these are these planes these
are because these are Stukas they're
like Dunkirk trailer that we keep saying
right like everyone says like all that
noise what it is you can see here on the
legs of the landing craft those are
propellers the Germans put them on to
literally terrorize ground troops stand
and that's why you hear that famous
noise for like any kind of plane diving
is because of these planes and they had
those are anti-tank cannons on
that's a big red means that big red one
right so that's that his division it
wasn't I mean that was was that a
separate Call of Duty game or rosette
yeah you held a big rival Wretch's
consulate specialized task on this clown
Gamecube
[Music]
this looks when we were playing through
call of duty 3 like all the sauce like I
don't hear stuff l gets hurt you chew
digs we executed the mission get me the
[ __ ]
[Music]
Jesus Lowen
Jesus return it tell them what we're all
about no mission too difficult no
sacrifice too great it sounds a lot like
him as well
oh man come to the bloody first you're a
long way from Texas farm boy man so do
you think I've taken from it like it
seemed like they're going the more it
seems like they're chewing not to just
keep comparing Saving Private Ryan it
sounds like they're doing like the
mission goes awry and then you and your
dudes decide to go do your own thing it
sounds like and then there's people who
are not comfortable with it
but also it seems like there's more
personal angle with heeds I mean like
this the fact that he says like you're
you're a long way from Texas maybe
implies that your character actually has
a little more personality in the sense
like a backstory and whatnot yes my
brother you were saying you want a small
squad kind of thing well I think one
shot like that I gathered um I'm gonna
just actually jump to it
apologies for people watching um
[Music]
it was a great where was that shot here
like this looks like your squat yeah
right like we haven't seen any other
theater all these shots seems pretty
connected like a British guy get
involved
I wonder compressor that's a Miss
division yeah just like I wonder like
how soon I mean if you're I wonder if
it's gonna be linear
jump back like jump forward in a
timeline but if it's gonna be right
after d-day that's probably still I
can't remember big red one was Utah
Beach or what or if they even like cuz
if it was Utah Beach then you're trying
to link up with paratroopers around
Karen tan and like st. Mary glaze but
that leads me to wonder if they were
like stranded British soldiers there too
that you read up meet up with mm-hmm all
in all I don't want to judge it off this
one trailer I'm kind of it's kind of I'm
kind of underwhelmed I'm a little
underwhelmed I could agree with you like
cuz I don't know it seems like I have
but again I don't know what I was hoping
for but it's just all so familiar right
yeah like this August is we've seen this
and we keep mentioning all these movies
and again games but like ultimately what
I'm excited for would be the story of
this of these guys I think judging from
the dialog that's happening between
these characters I think that the main
focus is going to be the characters in
your squad and trying to I suppose that
the game is going to try and like make
you feel connected to everyone in that
squad and like a moment like that where
you're face to face with like brutally
killing someone I think that it's gonna
drive this point home that you know Wars
and fun and games so they're I don't
know I'm I'm like I guess all I suppose
we already knew that we're gonna go for
a more serious tone by going to World
War two and it's I don't know I didn't
get and get the war isn't fun sense from
that trailer everything I just saw
looked like it's just seriously like
bombast and spectacle I don't know
so I guess is this your private that's I
guess that's the main character Minh
Texas so maybe it all is just focusing
on France huh from what we saw in that
trailer I mean they look we just got
done playing call of duty 3 and all
looked very familiar to me yeah I don't
think I'd be this down on if we just
hadn't played a lot of stuff it's just
interesting to see like these mission
like I can just see these missions you
know I mean like you're in a bell tower
sniping flamethrower yeah uh like that's
not Vin Diesel I would not be surprised
right um all right well that's it yeah
that's all we got I wanted that's all I
got for now I'm sure you know they have
the stream going on right now that's it
pretty much for this training answer
that's a Pangea the different variations
of Panzer Tiger Panzer yeah Oh what was
he doing that was that the does't the
beachfront and they have German soldiers
they're just taking pictures and huh
yeah I think that's gonna do it for us
thanks for joining us that was cool um
yeah I'm excited to see where they go
with this yeah stick around for the
lobby keeps last weekly live show that's
right up at 11:00 a.m. Pacific I don't
have any other streams today we might be
possibly playing 1740 later this week
yeah maybe Morrow the update was out
yeah the new update came a little bit
later yesterday so we got to it a little
late I didn't play that well I'd like to
seek some redemption so yeah maybe
tomorrow morning we'll take a look at
that but yeah thank you guys thank you
Michael and thank you Mike
Batman yeah thank you guys for joining
us again yeah lobby 11 a.m. stay tuned
for that that's actually come around the
corner huh and I would imagine we'll
talk more about this as well um yeah
thank you guys for joining us see you
thank you
[Music]